[Music]
foreign
landed on an Uncharted planet
we are the only survivors I don't know
where we are but there's something out
there
something alien
foreign
[Music]
run today
[Applause]
foreign
we're gonna get out of this
and we're gonna go home
[Music]
please
that isn't what you think
the cage
but we can help each other
[Music]
trust him
just a minute
but I Know How It Ends
I don't care what he can do he's not
getting out
you thought you could win
I don't have to win we both just have to
lose Marvel Studios Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum media experience it in 3D
February 17th to get tickets now
you got a problem here guy
[Music]
foreign
I had this Secret
there's a Darkness inside of me
it followed me here
and it's Gonna Keep Coming For Us
we share a certain history
assistant like any other ghost face
what is this place a shrine
we've got a lure him in
we execute them
hello let's play again
you know you're like the 10th guy to try
this right it never works out for the
[__] in The Mask
Maybe
something
different
that's why I'm gonna shoot you in the
[__] head
foreign
[Music]
can do nothing to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
a lot has changed in the last few years
the wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got superpowers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
from our father's call okay I feel like
maybe I should be writing all this down
your world would not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
now we're here all right
one job to do exceed the world
we fight powers like this
I can't do this take my powers back you
gave them to me so you would take them
back right
searching for worthy champion
he's known exactly what must be done
really what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
so we're here
[Music]
foreign
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
thank you
we're thieves but we help the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you
how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
follow me it's the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
she missed
no that's not good
I just sick of failing we could die it's
worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stock
woman
[Music]
my sister Lena is the only person who
believes in me want to help me with the
vid for my channel
she helped me with all my training you
are going to be such a great stumbler
that was Doppler but lately she's been
seeing this guy who I think is a bit of
a smarmy wanker
you know it's a truck oh my God Ria
chill out now I'm not being dramatic
but these people are evil
I found something
they are not taking her away without a
fight
strike down you or anyone else who tries
to get in my way
how about the bikini area
Let's Dance
we need to get Lena out
how Mischief is a foot
Nina's not going anywhere you little
[__]
rude
mom what are you doing now
[Music]
mistakes will come nothing changes
we are going to show Lena who these
people really are
y'all calling me crazy
[Applause]
did you see my kick of course I bloodied
it it was magical
blood
we gotta keep on you know damn well that
boy lasts until morning look at him uh
you're gonna help us get where we need
to go
there we go
[Music]
tails what the hell you doing boy get
out Billy D they all dead because of you
oh he's a slave then
you see chains on me
well Master around here barking orders
I ain't been no slave since I ran out
that Plantation
these Woods my world
it's just his arm behind me it's a
fugitive negross twice
they know about the real room oh slave
run and it's me
I'm not a warrior like you King yeah you
damn like
dog
hear me
jokes
no rules in war
you got to find yourself boy
find yourself
that's why we're gonna win this war we
get calls too we got a reason to win you
know hiding the truth will the truth is
just waiting to be found and God damn it
we found it
guards in this fight now
[Music]
thank you
hello
[Music]
my time I'm up I'm sorry I am you are
here for the cleaning
[Music]
and it doesn't wear them
did you convert when you married
back then I did something for my husband
that no one else could
the middle we are not married
he has a wife in the UK
how can you share knowingly we all Break
The Rules we set for ourselves
I need you to listen why did you come
here
where is Ahmed who are you
Los Angeles the City of Angels
more like the city of dirty little
secrets
people pay me to look into the
activities of its finest citizens I'm a
private detective
the name is Philip Marlow
how private are your investigation
what can I do for you I'd like you to
find my lover he disappeared without
saying goodbye
haven't we all
[Music]
what does my daughter want my mother was
in pictures
she must think there's something between
us
[Music]
looking for someone we're all looking
for someone I'll pay you a thousand if
you find him for me the puzzle has many
pieces I don't know what you're gonna
find
I'm going down the rabbit hole I'm not
afraid to take you with me I do like
this thing without not being afraid
we should be
they're all in on the conspiracy you'll
keep looking because you can't stop the
police won't touch you but I will
of all the people in Los Angeles who you
do not mess with they're top of the list
the key to Hollywood is knowing when
your game is up you go in there you're
coming out alive
as myself who wins Mr Marlow I will do
everything to put you in jail
and your secret
you'll have to keep those too
[Music]
foreign
I just arrived and it's amazing I can't
believe they let us keep all the
furniture I'm having the girls over
later so I'll see you tomorrow
I still can't tell if this house is
creepy or clean it's kind of cod every
place's birth group be on point I'm
really glad you guys are here Amen to
that
yeah my parents bought me this great
place because they think I'll live here
forever and they'll see me more often
the Tufts were matte all the tubs are
dead and gone and it's my place now I
can't just abide by the fact that she
bought the tub house she has to regret
coming back here
they took our phone
[Music]
I told her what would happen if she came
back
thank you
hello
why are there goats
[Music]
other
can I talk to you for a little bit
did you come inside right now there were
four of them what did we say you
shouldn't make things up when we're
talking about
can you open the door please
I'm not here to hurt you but you have to
stay here in the cabin with us families
throughout history have been chosen to
make this decision your family must
choose to willingly sacrifice one of the
three of you to prevent the apocalypse
we're not sacrificing anyone for every
no you give us
hundreds of thousands of people are
going to die
sweetheart close your eyes
will you make a choice
you have to somehow trust us we're
normal people just like you it doesn't
matter none of us believe you we will
never choose anyone
[Music]
I'm afraid the rule is that no one's
allowed to leave until you choose
do you really think it's all just a
coincidence I have to believe that my
son is gonna die his name is Charlie as
a mother I am begging you apparently
anyone who can stop this Andrew I saw
something there was something in the
light
yeah feel it now
I'm killing my family
I fail to choose a world will perish
we've been given the chance to decide
the fate of everyone
there is nothing more flawed and perfect
in this world than our family believe my
good choice
always together
I will ask for the last time will you
make a choice
[Music]
engine cameras this is the final call to
be a mess off a goodbye ceremony let's
move let's move let's move that means
you Tommy it's my fault dick face
well these might be our final moments
together this summer at Briarbrook the
fun isn't over yet
[Applause]
[Music]
now we all know the story 42 years ago
nurse act I think it's kicked out camp
firebrook this Eatery calm takes over
the forest now I know we've all been
trying to bring this hack back for years
we prick our finger hold up to the sky
and scream her name
something [__] horrible has happened
you can hear me please beat the mess
hall do you think maybe the ritual thing
might have caused Lauren she's not real
that's the reason why because she would
lure the children from their bunks By
Night collecting their blood in jars
that she hung from the trees
[Music]
foreign
let's go here let's try not to die
tonight
[Music]
what the hell happened
hey man
keep the car running people are dead you
[__] idiot
greatest idea what you've got I better
get the [__] picture
what does she want
s
[Music]
sir the police are here please
detective can we talk about this I'm
gonna pay you for your time stop he's
not a cop this is what my son does he
plays these games all that work for one
thousand dollars
if you're gonna steal
steal a lot
what are you doing here just wanted to
say hi I had a good time all right cool
see you around
I always assumed my son would inherit
all this he doesn't have the fortitude
each week
and of course I like him he's a
billionaire
we're celebrating what exactly are we
celebrating billions of dollars
roll up your sleeves trust me
you can't cheat on us man
that's why we never feel sorry for the
mark I really like you I really like
kids now you lied to me we're all human
just doing the best we can you cause
your mother anguish
and I will not have it she wants me gone
how do you think it says
not well
[Music]
what did you tell him I'm gonna take a
billion dollars and aim it in your
direction
[Music]
through
this is real
you sure
[Music]
I am so sorry
for what your daddy passed down to you
I wanted a child
gift of my life
I'm visiting my mother tomorrow
hi Karen it's Mom I'm just calling to
say that I'm so so so excited to see you
tomorrow you're my angel and I love you
okay I love you okay bye sweetie I love
you
are you at the airport I'm on my way I
just
it's not safe is it
what do you think I should do
I'm sure you'll do the right thing
sweetheart
welcome back I hit you with my car
what
oh
what was this that's my little assistant
health monitor
feeling sad about going home
us feel totally unreal
supposed to be leaving I don't know if
that's gonna happen
[Music]
many miles
dozens will become hundreds
hundreds will become thousands your
adventures will continue for years and
years this is a good hold I know
[Music]
sweet devotion
foreign
do you want the truth now
[Music]
Doom
the great Doom is coming
[Music]
sins of the father are heaped upon the
Sun
you have no clue the power of this book
possesses
mean to do this city harm
before it can be truly saved Gotham
be burned to the ground
Talking Dead folks reptile plagues it's
not natural
it's a cult that has a long ties to
Gotham
Spirit we come to us now I can't pretend
to know exactly what I'm about to face
but I do know
but I must stop it
we need to give this city purpose and
honor the damnation which for it
Mercy
what did this what's happening to you
what needs to happen
whose way must die
[Music]
hello Bruce you can't be
there Comes A Time in every child's life
when they have a fervent desire to go
somewhere dig for Hidden Treasure there
it is
Tom and Mr Twain would never have made
it easy as power for just anyone to find
to whomever should find this my story
lives forever in the pages of Tom Sawyer
they discover pirate's gold listen this
could be like our one time to do
something great let's find Tom Sawyer's
gold all right the quest is on you guys
have gotten closer than anyone ever has
with this I knew it how would you like
to become really rich plenty of folk are
gone searching for Tom Sawyer's gold
pirate gold it was you love Adventure if
we do this and we are back home in 24
hours buckle up
out of the crew it's only accessible
through the Bayou solve the puzzles
they're laid and look within to see
crack the code
discover an adventure let's move
Greater Than Fiction the map we're done
I'm not gonna let that happen
look Within
and you'll see
Patrick Muldoon there ain't gonna be no
stopping me this time I should have
known that you were behind this with
Joey Lauren Adams
this is so cool we're gonna see this
through we're gonna keep doing this
we've gone and done what no one's ever
done before
Tom Sawyer's gold thanks Mario
this was one or two things I haven't
quite told you about yet
[Music]